- Loin des tensions qui règnent
à la frontière entre l'Ukraine
et la Russie...
- Mon pays d'adoption...
- ... Nathalia et Eugène
se sont établis ici, dans
ce coin paisible de Gatineau.
- Dans le fond, on a eu
dededeux mariages : un à Montrél
et, par la suite, on est allés
en Ukraine pour un mariage
traditionnel.
- C'est Nathalia qui a quitté
l'Ukraine en premier,
il y a 22 ans.
- C'est un livre que j'ai écrit
en ukrainien sur le Québec.
- Son mari aime tellement
le Québec qu'il a écrit
un livre sur sa terre d'accueil
en ukrainien. Mais derrière
la tranquillité rererente,
l'inquiétude est bien réelle.
EUGÈNE LAKINSKY
- Bien sûr que je m'inquiète
pour ça. Et... c'est difficile.
Comme tu dis, Poutine peut
envahir l'Ukraine à tout moment.
La seule chose qui peut
l'empêcher, c'est les réactions
dedede l'Occident.
NATALIYA SENYUK
- Déclencher peut-être
une troisième guerre mondiale,
mais j'espère que non.
- Les parents d'Eugène,
par exemple, sont trop vieux
pour être rapatriés au Canada
si Vladimir Poutine
lance une attaque.
- Je dirais que la réponse
de l'Occident en général est
très faible.- - - - Le couple sr
une réponse plus ferme
de Justin Trudeau, avec
entre autres l'envoi d'armes
au gouvernement de Kiev.
- Sans armes, on ne peut pas
se défendre. Les armes,
c'est la garantie de la paix.
- Les États-Unis ont déjà
commencé à fournir de
l'équipement militaire.
L'ancien ambassadeur de
l'Ukraine à Ottawa croit que
le Canada doit emboîter le pas.
Une décision du gouvernement
Trudeau pourrait venir
dans les prochains jours.
En attendant, plusieurs
miononononont exprimé
leur solidarité sur Twitter.
Un soutien accueilli avec
scepticisme par cet expert.
JUSTIN MASSIE, prof.,
Départ. science politique, U
- C'est des photos où on dit :
"On est avec l'Ukraine", mais
sans offrir rien, ou très peu,
en forme de soutien concret.
- Natalya et Eugène
sont moins cynique
- La parole, c'est comme
une arme. Alors, on doit parler,
on doit comme disperser
l'information de tout
ce qui se passe.
- Car même si ces messages
ne sont pas suffisants, ils sont
au moins exprimés librement.
Une liberté d'expression
qui pourrait disparaître
aiaiaiaiaiaine si l'invasion rue
se concrétise.
Ici Laurence Martin